und man chef der herr auto erst drei
wochen erlassen die das können warum
sollte ich auch machen können das
richtige für mich ist ich werde noch
gebraucht ich fühle mich noch nicht zum
alten eisen sondern ja ist da ist jemand
ich kann auch was tun ich bin noch
nützlich und es gefällt mein im
unternehmen gehört der rentner wieder
fest dazu
die mythen der bereichsleiter bespricht
was die woche anfällt der austausch mit
den kollegen dem edv fachmann hatte er
gefehlt
45 jahre hatte er für den handelskonzern
otto in hamburg gearbeitet hat für das
unternehmen ein controlling system
aufgebaut dann ging er in rente
vor zwei jahren wurde sein wissen
plötzlich wieder gebraucht ich wollte
nicht erscheinen als wenn ich hier sind
klugscheißer bin sondern ich habe mich
den jungen leuten mit vornamen
vorgestellt
ich habe gesagt ich bin jung und das war
der entscheidende punkt wo die vertrauen
gefasst habe und das in ordnung wie
seine rentner hatte der konzern eine
eigene firma gegründet
sie werden befristet angestellt
projektbezogen das gehalt ähnlich wie
vor der rente
was ich mit meinem alter mit 67 noch
wohl fühlt und für das recht nicht zu
erleben und spaß macht ich muss nicht
ich glaube ich sollte möglichkeiten
geben dass personen die sich fit fühlen
und die gesund sind die spaß an der
arbeit haben auch noch weitermachen
dürfen
da sollte es irgendwie was geben und
nicht starr hier 65 und oder 67 jetzt
dort die ränder einführen
für den meister für gießereitechnik war
mit 65 jahren erstmal schluss er musste
in rente gehen so will es das deutsche
gesetz dann hat ihn der autokonzern
daimler für einen großauftrag
zurückgeholt als sogenannten senior
expert jetzt arbeitet günter schmidt mit
einem jungen kollegen zusammen tauscht
sein wissen aus immerhin bringt er rund
50 jahre berufserfahrung mit
wenn man auf die leute zugeht und man
spürt eine positive resonanz und
massiert respektiert und man schon rum
dann ist auch der spaßfaktor einer der
rund 500 rentner gehören inzwischen zum
expertenpool bei daimler
auch hier sind ihre verträge zeitlich
befristet auf maximal sechs monate
ich bin 69 jahre alt und ich werde hier
in deutschland bis ende 2017 arbeiten
und dann gehe ich zum arbeit nach
dänemark und dort kann ich so lange als
professor arbeiten wie ich möchte viele
menschen die früh in rente gehen sind
gelangweilt weil sie den ganzen tag
fernsehen für fünf jahre macht das spaß
aber wenn du zehn 15 20 oder gar 30
jahren rente bis ist das zu lang
demografie ist james palace fachgebiet
der professor der das
max-planck-institut in rostock leitet
gilt als koryphäe auf seinem gebiet der
gebürtige amerikaner hält das deutsche
rentensystem für veraltet
generationengerechtigkeit fehlanzeige
ich fühle dass wir überhaupt nicht
gerecht ich finde dafür die solidarität
diese partie für junge menschen in den
usa ist das flexibel du darfst niemanden
entlassen wegen seines alters nur wenn
leute nicht mehr arbeiten können geht
das so lange jemand arbeiten kann kann
er den job machen
in den usa kann ich so lange arbeiten
wie ich will
ob das in deutschland auch irgendwann
möglich sein wird jochen michalzik und
günter schmidt würden sich freuen
sie können sich vorstellen noch lange zu
arbeiten obwohl beide schon um die 70
sind